why did they call you lainey hawk i made
a shot in a basketball game
25 years ago must have been some shot
most places
no around here yeah
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about the first episode of a new
hbo
show called mayor of east town is this a
heavy character drama about a hometown
detective forced to grapple with her
personal demons
or is it a mystery about a killer who is
one step ahead of a small town
i was hooked in by the former having
grown up in a place that resembles east
town but i wasn't sure if this would
have a wide enough appeal to cover the
show
so i went ahead and watched the second
episode and now can confidently say that
it's both
and in my estimation it does both things
pretty well
don't worry though this video will only
be discussing episode 1
titled miss lady hawk herself i just
wanted to mention that if you thought
the show was leaning too hard towards
the character development
at the expense of the mystery it does
change gears
and lean in on the crime side of things
in the second installment
they lay it right out there with the
title which has to be one of the least
catchy ones i've heard recently
it's about the person and the place and
that should be of equal
importance with the mystery episode one
is about
introductions east town is important
here because it's the kind of place
where everyone knows
everyone else and they might even be
related it's the kind of place where a
detective sergeant might get a call
about a peeping tom
on her personal cell while she's still
in bed or that your ex-husband might buy
the house right behind yours because he
got a great deal
and it's the kind of place where
addiction seems to be touching most of
the family's lives in one way or another
and we're making a shot and a state
championship basketball game is
something that people are still talking
about
25 years later the city of east town
does a lot of the heavy lifting
and fleshing out these characters in
their connection with it and i will come
back around to talk about that more at
the end of this video
now let's look at what actually happened
in the first episode
after the ferret looking prowler we get
an idea of what mayor's days are like
at the station we see her get called out
on tv
for not solving a missing person case
that's now
a year old here we see her go straight
to blaming the victim
she brings up the fact that katie was a
known drug abuser
that had a history of prostitution she
tells the chief that the girl's body is
probably at the bottom of the delaware
river
on the other hand when she goes out on a
burglary call where she knows the victim
and the suspect we get the idea that
she's not without compassion
as we see her asking about why the
suspect freddie's
house is so cold and when she learns
that the power company has turned it off
which is illegal
she's determined to help him out in that
situation her strengths and weaknesses
are both out there for us to see
and what's interesting is she has the
same personal connection to both of
these cases
they're both related to women that she
played on that state championship
basketball team with
we also get an idea of how her family
life is
we see her shopping for an aquarium for
a baby turtle
we see that she has a concern about the
price telling us that she's not exactly
rolling in the dough
but probably more importantly that she's
caring for her grandson who she
says has trouble focusing on task
as we meet her mother and her
college-bound daughter
who is helping to take care of the
grandson but not his mother
mayor gets a surprise that kind of
overshadows things in a way that makes
it hard to understand
how this family gets along under normal
circumstances
her ex-husband whose call she'd been
avoiding is getting remarried and she
was the last to find
out and this gives her an excuse to be
cranky with everyone
but she's also a real pain in the ass
here and it makes you wonder if she's
always that way
and she's just looking for an excuse
rather than the other way around
either way while everyone else in town
seems to be going to frank's house for
his party
mayor goes over to laurie's house lori
has been her best friend since
childhood and they head over to the high
school where we see that
beth laurie mayer and dawn were all
teammates on that state championship
team as they're getting called to the
floor mayor brings up dawn's appearance
on tv
and she won't let up dawn says it's not
about you mayor not everything is it's
about finding my daughter
and i mean it kind of is she's got a
point there
but at the same time it is kind of about
mare isn't it at least from what we've
seen from the police station
she seems to be the head person in
charge of this case
it's a year old the chief says they have
nothing
and this is all clearly a sore spot for
our detective
by the end of the episode it will turn
out to be one of two cases
in east town that involve young women in
episode 1 we also meet the single mother
aaron
her scary dad and the disinterested and
cruel father of her child
the opening shot of aaron which is
almost a mere image to where we last see
her in the episode
tells us most of what we need to know
about this character
she seems to genuinely love her son and
becoming his mother at this young
age has changed her life and isolated
her
we spent a decent amount of time in this
episode getting to know her
getting ready to root for her and then
having it pulled out right from
underneath us
as her ex dylan's new girlfriend brianna
plays a cruel trick impersonating a new
love interest
online and then luring her to the high
school hangout spot to beat her up
it's pretty brutal all the way around
like i said the setup makes her a
sympathetic character
and the way everything plays out is just
really cruel
luckily at the last moment mare's
daughter siobhan shows up with her
friends and they're able to break things
up but then aaron walks off by herself
only to be found murdered in a nearby
creek the next morning
considering we know this is a story
about a detective and that it's gonna be
a murder mystery
a lot of the scenes watching aaron start
to feel kind of inevitable
and by the time we see this shot where
she gets a smile on her face thinking
about the upcoming
date riding her bike over to her
friend's house is about the same time we
know that she's gonna end up dead
i guess what is compelling about it and
what makes it work is you can totally
understand why she would fall for this
she needs to believe that this guy she's
going to meet is real
so it's not hard to imagine her falling
for it when we
know that this is a bad idea i guess the
least interesting part of the first
episode for me
was this introduction of richard the
potential love interest for mayor
but their introduction does a pretty
good job of highlighting how
mayor sees thing i mean this is the
perfect setup for her right
she's upset that her ex-husband's
getting remarried that nobody told her
about it
she goes to the bar there's this
good-looking
interesting new guy from out of town
that doesn't know anything about her
or the place where she can't escape and
it really takes some convincing to get
her
to actually get involved here it turns
out they have this thing in common they
both peaked early their big thing
happened when they were younger
his being that he wrote a good book he
won a prestigious award
and we'll have to see where things go
from here because after they hook up she
goes home
and she does get the call and she'll be
tasked with trying to find out who
killed aaron
i mentioned that her daughter was
helping to take care of her grandson but
isn't the boy's mother
that indicates that there's another
child and we do see mayor have a vision
of him or see him in a dream before she
wakes up we don't know anything about
what happened to him
or when it happened we do know that the
child is four years old
so it may be recent and it may have
something to do with why she wasn't able
to find out what happened to katie when
she went missing
i mentioned how i'd come back to the
idea of how the small town and
everyone's connection to it sort of sets
things up
when everyone knows everyone else that
means that the chances of the killer
being an anonymous character go
down not only is everyone a suspect but
the connections mean that there could be
complications for mare as things come to
light
we've already seen that her personal
connections play a part in how she
approaches her job
and just how her famous basketball shot
colors how everyone sees her
her familiarity with the locals of east
town might color how she goes about
interacting with potential suspects at
this point
we don't know if the two crimes are
connected we don't know if the prowler
has anything to do with it
or if he really looks like a ferret
mayor did see someone lurking on her way
home and scared him off i'm not sure if
there's something else going on there
we have gotten an idea about who the
characters are though
about the town they live in and it all
has me excited to jump into the mystery
next week
i think we'll spend some time trying to
figure out if mare's the way she is
because of things that have happened to
her or if she's ultimately her own worst
enemy that's brought much of this
on herself i think it's safe to say that
it's probably a little bit of both i
mean
yeah she did basically blame katie for
getting disappeared
but she also did get out of bed to
respond to the call about the prowler
which does tell us something
i thought the performances were pretty
fantastic here it's not a huge surprise
considering the cast but
kate winslet seems to be pulling off the
accent as far as i can tell
her mentioning the clean wooder for the
turtle caught my attention
and i'm not from that area specifically
but that is a
accent i've heard before i thought the
ankle injury was a great idea that added
a lot to every scene that came
after it it sort of made her outsides
match her insides or something along
those lines just watching her struggle
to get around
in her short run as erin kaylee spaney
pretty much
nailed it and her father reminded me of
quite a few people i came in contact
with growing up
really all of the locals seemed real and
familiar and i'm looking forward to
getting to know them all better
the scene where beth breaks down and
tells mare that she just wishes her
brother would die that he would get it
over with already was really powerful
there's definitely darkness underneath
and there's plenty of misery to go
around
but from what i've seen so far it
doesn't seem to get stuck there
i guess another one of these limited
series i watched was
i know this much is true kind of felt
like something you had to endure
rather than just watch and take it all
in and i don't think this is going in
that same direction but we'll have to
wait and see
and i think that is the perfect place to
bring this video to an
end let me know in the comments what you
think about the show what do you think
about happened to
aaron and where you think things are
heading please like this video if you
enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon